i said i would do a video on inflection
points so let's get an intuition on
inflection points so let me draw a graph
let's say
i don't know this let me draw a little
bit neater than i did in the last video
i think i rushed through that one a
little bit more than i wanted to
so let's say that that is
the y-axis
that's the x-axis and let's say my graph
looks something like this
it's
comes down
like that and that
and it kind of flattens out there
and we said that inflection points are
another example when the derivative
equals zero i don't know if i do it
properly here i wanted this to flatten
out a little bit but you could take my
word for that at this point right here
the slope is flat maybe the graph looks
a little bit more like that
right if i were to draw a line that
represents the slope at that point it
would look something like this
it would look something like this
right
well i'm trying my best i think you get
the point
right
there's three types of places where you
could have a zero slope
a minimum maxima or an inflection point
so what what is the
um
what what will the first derivative look
like if at this point or around this
point let's draw a chart and see if we
can get the intuition
i'm a little bit scatterbrained today
yesterday i recorded a video and i added
wrong let's see
so if this is f of x
let's see if we can sketch out what f
prime of x or what the derivative of
this function looks like i'm going to do
it down here just because
we can kind of follow along the same x
so let me draw the x and y axis so let's
say the y this is the y axis again
and there's
that's let's see that's the x-axis and i
want to graph f prime of x
so f prime of x
actually let me erase
a little bit of this let me erase this
i don't want this to get in the way
we care around this point
so
what is the slope doing as we approach
that point
well here the slope is really negative
right
safe at that point
and then as we move arbitrarily to the
right it becomes a little bit less
negative
then here it becomes even less negative
until finally it becomes zero
so if this was
if this is if we're going to draw f
prime of x at this point we said that
the slope was really negative
and then it becomes a little bit less
negative it's getting less less less
negative and then it approaches a zero
slope right there
right but then what's it doing right now
in the previous example when we we saw a
concave upwards graph maybe a parabola
we saw that you know that the slope
would just kept increasing right you
kind of the slope just kept increasing
and you'd go up that way but in this
situation the slope becomes zero
right it keeps becoming less negative up
to zero but then what happens as you go
here it starts the slope starts
decreasing again it's a little bit
negative there then it becomes more
negative then it becomes more negative
so the slope
that the graph of the slope will
actually look something like that
right it starts off really negative
becomes less and less negative becomes
less and less negative
zero at the point of inflection that's
the slope at the point of inflection
and then it becomes more negative again
so what will the second derivative of
that look like
let me draw that here
i can even draw it on on top of that
same graph but maybe it's easier if i
draw it here
well the second derivative look like
well the second derivative is just the
slope of the slope
right so it's a slope of this line
so here we have a very high slope
right the slope is very positive there
then it becomes a little bit less
positive
then it becomes
a little bit
even less positive until it becomes flat
here
right
and then it becomes negative and more
negative and more negative so if this
point
is
this point
the second derivative will look
something like this right back here at
this value of x let's say that this is
this value of x
we have a really high slope and the
slope just becomes a little bit flatter
a little bit flatter until it gets to
zero and then it starts going negative
so the second derivative is going to
look like this it's going to you know it
doesn't have to be a line but i'm kind
of this is a typical example you might
see so this would be f prime prime of x
now what is that what is that what can
we
now take away from this well when you
you learn your your concativity rules
and all of that you learn that if the
second derivative is positive you're
concave upwards so if
f prime prime
at you know whatever point at
at some point a let's say x is equal to
a
if f prime of well first of all we know
that if f prime of a is equal to zero we
know the slope is zero there right
and that's what this horizontal
represented and so that tells us that
it's either an inflection point a
maximal point or a minimum point right
and then we learned in the previous
video that if your second derivative
at a
is greater than zero
then you're concave upward and you might
want to review that that video or
actually just draw it and think about it
for yourself i don't want to take any of
this uh for granted it's it's the the
value of learning this is to get the
intuition not to memorize these rules
and we also learned that if f prime
prime of a
is negative that we're going
concave downwards
and now this example
what is f prime if this was a right here
what's f prime prime of a in this
example well this is a right here
well it's zero
right because you see the the the graph
of the slope flattens out here it starts
going negative again here
so we know that if the second derivative
at a well if the first derivative point
is zero it's either a maximum a minimum
or an inflection point
and if we know that if the second
derivative is also zero then it's
definitely an inflection point so really
that's the intuition behind all of you
know the maximum and minimum problems
that you'll you'll see in your in your
first semester calculus course and uh
now i i hope you have the intuition and
we can do some problems see in the next
video